hello good morning and welcome to a
special Sochi Ridge on Sunday we're live
at the Conservative Party Conference
here in Birmingham for you but what a
difference a year makes 12 months ago
the chancellor where she sooner can
prime minister Boris Johnson who was
speaking to a conservative party in
pretty good spirits less than two years
after a huge election Victory well the
mood has to put it mildly changed it's
hard to think of a more difficult
combination of problems facing a new
prime minister taking her fast
conference as leader as labor extends
huge poll leads both Liz truss and the
chancellor quasi quateng will give
speeches that could already decide their
political fate meanwhile there's talk
with a budget Rebellion by her own MPS
possible letters of no competence and a
row over a new age of austerity all that
of course with the mortgage mortgage
Market in chaos and pressure on the
pound the new PM may already be in
survival mode
or we have got a great list of guests to
take you through that story for you in a
moment we'll be joined here in
conference by the chair at the
conservative party Jake Berry
and here on his own patch we've got the
mayor of the West Midlands Andy's
streets
with the conservative plans under
extreme scrutiny by businesses and the
markets we'll be talking to the director
general of the UK's biggest business
organization the CBI that is Toby Danko
and the treasury committee has
criticized the chancellor for not
releasing an official forecast of his
spending plans it's chair Mel stride
will join us and we'll also be talking
to the former Junior Minister and
concept of MP Heather wheeler on the
shows and another very important guest
for us after Russia's illegal annexation
of some 15 of the country will be
talking to the Ukraine MP Alessia
vasilenko
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
great to have you with us here in
Birmingham this morning well joining us
now is the chair of the concept of party
and also leading voice from red wall
conservative MPS Jake Barry great to
have you good morning thank you for
having me with us uh right first things
first let's get something cleared up
hours after the mini budgets last Friday
on Friday last Friday did you celebrate
with the chancellor and a group of hedge
fund managers at a champagne reception
well look we often have Greek receptions
for donors in the conservative party in
fact these people should be lauded
because we don't have Public Funding of
political parties and these are people
who go up make money and donate to
political parties in the same way as
they do for the labor party and the
liberal Democrats in terms of that get
together it wasn't a get-together of
hedge fund managers it was actually
Britain's sort of leading entrepreneurs
yes I was there but it's the sort of
normal drum beat of treasures at events
as we call them in the conservative
party that we have all the time so there
weren't hedge fund managers there uh I
mean I'm sure there were or there was I
think one that I know of but in terms of
the rest of the people there lots of
them are people who've grown in smart
businesses in fact the conversations I
had because it was my job before I did
this was people who work in the property
industry and what they were all saying
is they backed this government's drive
to create growth in the economy because
they understand that you cannot have a
riding tide of rising tide of prosperity
that flows under every door in this
country without first creating growth in
the economy just want to look at
the details from the Sunday Times this
morning so as the markets crashed you
acknowledge you were at the
multi-million pound Chelsea home of the
Tory donor along with other donors
including hedge funders financiers many
of whom may have made money from the
crash in the pound how is that in any
way appropriate well I'm not sure that
any of them did make money from the
crash in the pound and of course you
will know well that the pounds actually
had its best week against the dollar
since 2020 if you look at the close this
week
aspersions against what people may or
may have not done whose name was
absolutely clear well I think people can
read the Times if they want to let's be
absolutely the home of somebody who has
acknowledged taking short positions on
the power before absolutely clear this
is part of the normal drum beat of the
treasurer events within the conservative
party I was there there was no
confidential information that was
discussed it was a sort of a
get-together with some of Britain's
leading entrepreneurs who by the way we
should thank for creating growth in our
economy and being on this drive to Great
growth for every ordinary working family
in this country about our plans for
growing the economy how was the chance
of mood as he drunk champagne well I'm
not even sure that Chancellor was
drinking champagne I think he was
drinking a soft drink but um you know he
was absolutely clear that he has set out
a path for this country to create growth
and the reason we want to create growth
is to ensure that every family who is
really worried about things like their
mortgage rate would have been terrified
if the government hadn't have taken
action on energy bills people seem to
forget that just a few weeks ago we were
talking about four million businesses
going bust we were talking about tens of
millions of people losing their job we
were talking about the average household
having an energy bill of six thousand
pounds and now we're talking about
the market and we're talking about the
bank of England having to step in with a
65 billion pound bailout in order to
stop a run on Entry the action the
government has taken we have cut on
average a thousand pounds from people's
energies bills we have stopped those
millions of budgets going bust look on
the mortgage Market I understand there
is concern there is what would you say
to people who are really concerned about
the mortgage Market whatever irritated
them is the government is working both
with the bank of England and you saw
that both the chancellor and the Prime
Minister have been working with the obr
and the bank of England to ensure that
we have stability in the mortgage Market
I don't believe that will come I
understand it's a distressing time for
people I understand people are worried
about their mortgage but you know the
government is working to ensure that we
have stability in that market for every
household in this country now the
article that Sunday Times article also
says the chancellor gave insights as
they put it into future government
spending cuts at the event can you rule
that out that he made those comments
well I certainly didn't hear him make
those comments um have you asked him
whether he did well I was there so I
listened to what he said and what he
talked about was his plan for growth and
what he said categorically rule out that
he didn't have those conversations with
anyone at the event can you well I I
don't categoric rule it out because I
didn't hear every conversation but in
terms of what you asked me is the
chancellor made a statement or a speech
talking about future platens I can
categorically rule out that in that
speech which is what I heard we were all
having our own conversations
I mean you don't know about
conversations that people have privately
but I would ask anything like this so
yeah I can categorically rule out that
in terms of the address he made to the
group of people who were there as part
of this normal treasurer's event he did
not give any insight into future plans
and I'm sure in terms of his private
conversations he didn't give any insight
okay well let's look at the future plans
now are you going to cut spending to
bring public finances under control well
I think I think every household
understands that actually the reason
this government is going for growth is
because when you're struggling with your
household budget as many households are
you need to grow your personal household
budget in many cases people's pay
packets that's why we're going for
growth but you also need to manage your
expenditure and I don't think it's
unreasonable for the government to say
that the public sector should look at
its expenses in the same way that every
single household is doing in this
country so that that means what we've
heard from the government is there's
going to be a drive to trim fat in terms
of government expenditure
you use that word trim fact what do you
mean by trim fat where is that I think
everyone would accept that you know
there are efficiencies that can be found
in terms I'll give you one example you
know the government has set out ways and
which is going to seek to recover the
bounce back loans many of which were
taken incorrectly we heard about the
whole scale forward in bounce back loans
that's a way we can recover how much
money is that though come on I mean
we're currently spending more on debt
interest payments than the entire
education budget you can have to find a
lot of fat well isn't that the reason
you that's the reason the government
wants to grow the economy because we
didn't have a choice when I'm asking you
directly where is that let me answer the
question then we have a choice in front
of us don't we can keep doing more of
the same which is low growth high taxes
stagflation as it's called or we can do
what the government has done which is
try and create high growth with a lower
tax economy and the reason to do that
like every household budget I've
mentioned earlier the reason to do that
is if you have increasing bills you have
two choices you can either cut the bills
we cut your usage or you can increase
the amount of money you have coming into
the household that is exactly what this
government is trying to do we are trying
to increase the amount of money coming
in I.E grow the economy we're not doing
that as some academic exercise we're
doing because it's right for every
household in this country while at the
same time it will be completely
irresponsible of any government not to
say in the way that households are
finding Savings in their budget it would
be completely responsible to say the
public sector or government Department
should in some way be immune from the
decisions that other households are
having to take the same way that people
who are earning the uh you know over 150
000 pounds a year will be immune as
they're getting a tax cut well they are
you're right they are getting a tax cut
but that's because these are the
entrepreneurs who drive our economy but
the more important thing is
drops through the letterbox next month
will have had their National Insurance
go every single person who's got an
energy bill when their energy bill drops
through the letterbox this month we'll
see that the government has capped
prices to help with household budgets
and on the question of energy bills as a
percentage of GDP as a government we
have done more than any other government
in Europe to support households and I
think more than anything else that shows
how we're on the side of working
households I just want to come in on the
phrase that you used about entrepreneurs
who drive the economy because I do think
that a lot of workers will find that
quite offensive to be completely honest
you know you're talking about they're
very wealthy at driving the economy but
what about all the other people who also
drive the economy and we know don't we
from analysis and it's only the people
at the top the richest people who are
going to benefit overall from the tax
changes that were introducing well sorry
we don't know that from analysis I'm
sorry that is complete and uh
no I'm sorry that is simply incorrect so
let's put it on the record what we're
doing every single working person in
this country is going to see a cut in
their National Insurance next month oh
sorry this month now and we also know
that the lower paid in this country as a
percentage of their income pay more in
National Insurance than higher earners
so in fact if there's a percentage of
income it is giving a bigger tax cut to
those lower earners than it is to the
top owners so I'm saying what you're
saying is simply incorrect you know
analysis is wrong and I am proud to be
part of a government that is
prioritizing tax cut for every worker in
this country not just those in the top
end a benefit's going to increase in
line with inflation well I'm not going
to come on here and make financial
statements that's a matter for the
chancellor and we will know in in due
course what is going to happen the
benefits
they would have got 19 pounds a week
more wouldn't they if the changes
announced by Rishi sunak to upgrade our
benefits in line with inflation and it
had gone on how much given the inflation
pressures uh given you know what we've
seen with energy bills and she
acknowledged going up food inflation
double figures how much more a week do
you think people in benefits should be
able to have to really you know meet
that pressure what 19 pounds a week is
that too much 10 pounds a week I've
already said I won't make it's not for
me to make fiscal announcements in
relation to benefits I know and
understand and this government knows and
understands the huge pressures that
households are facing and that's why we
are pivoting to grow the economy because
in fact it's only by growing the economy
that we can ensure that Britain can get
a pay rise we can ensure that people get
really decent public services that they
rely on and we can also ensure that we
can properly fund
both our public services but all the
other thing the government has to do
like you know we are you know seeing a
threats from the East we need to
properly fund our Armed Forces we need
to properly fund the police we need to
properly fund our NHS that is the reason
we're growing the economy and it's for
every working household in this country
that we are doing that I just want to
have a look if I may at a chart this is
balances from the resolution Foundation
now this has shown the impact of the tax
changes in the budget and also if I know
you haven't concrete if you haven't
confirmed that you haven't confirmed it
the expected changes that we could say
to Universal Credit if their benefits do
not rise in line with inflation and you
can see there it is the very richest
households those on the right of the
screen who are going to be benefiting
because of your policy changes all those
people on the bottom impacted by the
benefits these are lower incomes
negatively impacted is that fair right
I'm really sorry I can't actually see
the table what I go back and say is that
what we're doing for every household in
this country is ensuring that they get a
cut in their tax bill next month when
that payslip drops through the letterbox
or rise to our email we've taken action
on energy bills which people will you
know
we were going to lose tens of millions
of jobs in this country because of the
cost of energy for business we've taken
action that isn't now going to happen we
were going to see inflation Peak at 19
predicted to Peak at 19 because we've
taken action on energy bills that now
won't happen inflation isn't some
academic figure that anchors and
economists and politicians and
journalists are talking about it has a
huge impact on every household in this
country that is why we're taking action
that is why we want to grow the economy
because we want every single household
to benefit from economic growth the
reporters the reports in the papers
today that Liz truss advised King
Charles not to attend the next climate
change Summit and he of course is
someone who has been quite supportive
should we say of the green agenda and
can you commit to The Net Zero carbon
emissions Target by 2050. the government
remains committed to The Net Zero Target
by 2050. so that's that so it's a change
so it's yes okay thank you I appreciate
the clear answering that and I just want
to look a bit over overall at the
direction that you're taking because in
the telegraph you've got an article
today you say we're overturning the
tired economic Orthodoxy that's
prevailed for decades and of forging a
new direction for the country how big a
change is this
well it's rather to say how big it
changes I've been really clear what
we're doing we're seeking to create
growth in the economy I've been really
clear about why we're doing it we are
doing it to ensure that there is a
riding Rising spring tide of prosperity
that flows through every household in
this country that's what we're doing
that's why we're doing it and it's
because this government's values are on
the side of hard-working families across
the UK from you're quite there a new
direction for the country overtiming the
Orthodoxy that's prevailed for decades
so conservative administrations as well
as labor wants what's your mandate to
change what multiple governments have
done
well certainly the Prime Minister we
have a Monday on a 2019 Manifesto and
don't forget that 2019 Manifesto set out
two things it set out that we wouldn't
increase taxes and in fact we've
complied with that by reversing the
National Insurance rise it set out that
we would drive to create economic growth
and that's exactly what the prime
minister's doing we have an absolute
mandate from that Manifesto and we will
continue to deliver we really believe
you've got an apps like mandate
Manifesto there was nothing about
scrapping the 45p rate attacks Boris
Johnson promised the government wouldn't
go back to austerity he won a landslide
promising be expanding more nurses more
funding for schools more polices in
seats like yours absolutely right that
is why we're trying to create growth but
you're also talking about public
spending cuts you'll talk about trimming
the fat that is very difficult language
I
expect this government there's no such
thing as government money it's taxpayers
money but do you know I think do you
British acknowledge the key shift in the
the this government and what's going on
before you have said that you're about
to rip up the Orthodoxy of decades of
previous governments how can you say
that you had a mandate from the last
election well I think the British public
just to answer your question would
rightly expect this government when we
are spending their money it's not
government money it's their money would
rightly expect this government to make
the difficult Choice
sorry I'm answering the question that I
was halfway through when you interrupted
me with this government to ensure that
we do not waste their money and we
deliver efficient Public Services look
on the Orthodoxy I don't think that it's
a new Orthodoxy for the conservative
party to say that it wants to deliver
growth and what we have seen over the
last couple of decades is a high tax low
growth economy and the truth is that if
we are going to change that not for the
government not for Bankers as you sought
to say earlier saying this is this is
government's motivation
households in this country
that's the right motivation and in truth
tell households work people know that
when their bills arrive they can either
cut their consumption or they can get
higher salary or higher wages go out
there and get that new job what's the
approach the government is taking we are
saying taxes
so households can afford their bills as
well as the brilliant what we're doing
on energy bills you were talking about
what people expect to see from
government what the public would like
and let's have a look shall we uh you
got Paul from Thursday now I accept
they're having different polls but this
one from Thursday you got piles showing
labor has a 33 point lead now when I
know pulse fluctuate and I know we're
outside of an election
is quite jaw dropping between a labor
League like this since the 1990s it's
not just this poll opinion 19 point lead
the prime minister's net approval
falling from -9 to minus 30 37 in a week
that's worse than Boris Johnson well let
me tell you also last Thursday there
were two violations in my constituency
of Rosendale and Darwin both of which we
won with an increased vote for the
conservative party the difference
between that poll and those by-elections
last week is it's a forced decision
where people have to make a choice and I
know and believe that when we get to
that general election when we have
delivered that growing economy when we
have ensured that the benefits is felt
by every household in this country that
it'll be a very different result than
shown in that snap Hole uh you know a
few days after the government has done a
mini fiscal events okay well that's
certainly uh interesting to see your
opinion on how different conservatives
are feeling at the minute it has been
I'll be honest quite difficult to find
people to talk to this conference
um perhaps because a lot of them are are
staying away or they don't necessarily
feel that they want to talk to the media
right now there are also reports that
some conservative MPS are even prepared
to vote against
the budget or the financial measures in
the budget if they did that would that
be treated as a vote of confidence would
they lose the word yes they would lose
the weight correct and so do you think
as well I mean although that is a
decision for the cheap whip but as far
as I'm concerned yes then they would
lose the web for doing that
um reports also saying that there are
people who are even thinking about
trying to find a way of in stating a new
leader bypassing the members having an
ability to have a say in having NPS to
decide what do you think the ration to
that would be well I mean what I would
say to colleagues is we have a new prime
minister she has a mandate both from
colleagues on our membership she
absolutely has a plan for this country
that will create economic growth the
benefit of which will be felt by every
household in this country we need to get
on and Implement that plan we need to
unify behind that plan and add go out
there into our communities in Lancashire
across this country and Advocate our
core values of why we are doing this and
I'm sure that if we do that it will lead
ultimately to long-term elections
um it's been really interesting talking
to T today I generally wasn't really
sure
um you know how your sort of manner
would be your demeanor would be uh today
um you know you're someone who's always
you know advocated for leveling up right
you you've sought out people who may not
naturally be conservative voters you
kind of care about the communities
outside of London
how comfortable
are you personally with where the
conservative party is right now and the
way forward I'm absolutely comfortable
with it and I tell you why because this
idea that I read in the media that
people in communities across our United
Kingdom not just in the north but in the
southwest all over the country vote of
the conservatives because in some way
they wanted a labor government they
wanted a sort of labor light government
whatever it may be in my experience I'm
not pollster but in my experience of
knocking on 14 000 doors over the summer
is just completely wrong what families
want is the government that is
absolutely determined to create growth
for them to increase their salary to
deliver world-class public services to
be on their side and that's what they
are getting with this government and on
the point of levelinga in the new
tax-free investment zones that the
government's announced around the
country we are going to see that agenda
turbocharged and we're going to see new
businesses opening creating those highly
paid secured jobs that's why I got into
politics I'm proud to be part of a
government that is going to deliver for
the community
and communities that I have the
privilege of calling home I've lived and
worked in the north my entire life I
know this government is going to deliver
from the north and I'm proud to be part
of that story Gamble and growth though
isn't it it's all it's all or nothing on
growth how are you so sure that you guys
are right
in public as you've seen the polls are
wrong other conservative MPS are wrong
many of the people in the markets are
wrong how confident are you well look
markets both react to government
statements and in my experience having
tracked this over a very long period
often overreact so let's see where the
markets are
overreacted no no they can overact I
don't know if they did in this case I'm
not an economist but let's see whether
markets are in six months time I think
that's a far better measure of the
success of the mini budget fiscal event
but secondly look in terms of creating
that growth let me tell you a little
story my sister-in-law went to hospital
with her father who lives in the care
home and has dementia who fell over and
they had a suspected broken hit he was
in that a e Department with dementia
confused not knowing where he was for 10
hours waiting to see a doctor that is
completely unacceptable and the reason
this government wants to create growth
is to ensure that we have the money
coming into the country like it comes
into every household when you create
growth to give more money to the NHS to
deliver world-class Public Services
that's what people want to see that is
the what this government is going to do
and that's why I'm proud to be part of
it okay
Jake Barry there chair of the
conservative party
well we've been talking about many of
the issues as this morning we touched on
those poll leads for labor mortgage
rates and of course at talk potentially
of real-time cuts to benefit so nervy
times for the conservatives around the
country but of course we especially in
places like the West Midlands where we
are today far from a natural Heartland
for the party lots of marginal seats
here and the most high profile elected
conservative in the area is the West
Midlands mayor Andy Street and he joins
us now thank you very much for being
with us good morning and now before we
get on to policy I want to talk to you
about the Tweet exchange that you had
with a certain young conservative just
explain to us what happened oh well we
should do this quickly because it's not
a huge issue but there's an important
Point behind it young conservative
coming here for the conference described
in his Twitter Birmingham was quote
unquote a dump now you might say turn
the other cheek but there is a really
important point about how perceptions of
cities are we have spent decades trying
to rebuild the perception of Place think
of the success of the Commonwealth Games
this summer I think of the International
Investment that comes in on the back of
that so my job is always to defend the
brand the reputation of this city and
that's why I took him to task on Twitter
it's also damaging for the conservative
party brand isn't it well I want
everyone who comes here for conference
this week is why we so enjoy hosting it
and frankly we'd enjoy hosting it was
the labor party as well to go away
thinking this place is really making
progress back them they'll make further
progress so I can't have anyone in the
conservative party off message now I'm
really interested to have you on the
program this morning because genuinely I
don't know where your head is at right
the last thing I can see that you
tweeted um publicly about politics other
than Birmingham related or West Midlands
related thing it was on the 5th of
September when Liz truss won the
leadership contest you said the first
thing for Liz truss is in tomorrow's
interest got to be getting a grip on the
cost of living pressures then doubling
down on leveling up now you could argue
of course that the energy support
package was getting a grip on those cost
of living freshers I'm sure you would
welcome that how is doubling down on
leveling up going yeah so let's just
acknowledge the first point that you've
been fair about two weeks ago everyone
was saying is the government going to
act on the cost of living pressure and
more precisely the energy cost and they
did decide simply and of course we know
that as of yesterday when prices would
have gone up the new price regime comes
in and for a person with an average
semi-detached house in this city it's a
saving of about 1100 pounds against what
it would be so there was decisive action
on that and we should all acknowledge
that in terms of leveling up that's
going to take a little longer part of
course of this conference is to show
that if you invest in a region like this
we will deliver we will pay back but the
first real piece of evidence of leveling
up is of course the announcement in the
million budget of the investment zones
and I fervently welcome that we are
sitting actually just next to probably
the most successful Enterprise Zone
anywhere in Britain that has seen the
Redevelopment of the city center here
investment zones which have been many
more places is a sort of Enterprise Zone
on steroids the policy definitely works
we've proved that we want to be as quick
as can to get that off the ground from
the interview with Jake Barry it's very
clear that the government is not going
to go back on scrapping the 45p a rate
of additional tax if you're a
millionaire that would be worth 55 000
pounds to you in a tax cut and they've
also not confirmed that benefits will be
operated in line with inflation is that
leveling up
so that's a that is a total decision
across the whole country of course
leveling up is much more focused and
that's why I've given you the answer I
have but to be really clear for us to
level up generally you've got to lift
lift the qualifications and the
aspirations of the people who are
probably the just about managing as many
many of those in this city and for them
the the energy price action was
absolutely critical and also of course
for them the National Insurance
reduction applied to everybody was
critical but the most important thing is
where is the jobs of the future going to
come from and that's why I was also very
keen to see some of the things in the
statement which were about in business
investment because they will produce the
new sectors The Net Zero sectors of the
future the jobs for people in this city
but if you are a just about managing
family in Birmingham as you say and you
look at the budget and you think oh my
goodness me um I welcome the support and
energy with Bill as well how am I going
to afford my food shop I'm really
worried about my public services and you
hear the government say they want to
make spending cuts but they're also
going to give a fifty five thousand
pound tax cut to the very wealthiest
they have not yet said they are
definitely going to make any spending
cuts they're saying they're reviewing
public spending every government says
that in time because they have to
balance the books nothing has come
through actually if you look at public
spending we're actually committed at the
moment to the huge increases in the
public spending that Boris Johnson's
government brought about and probably
the most important thing if you ask
people in this city would be the
investment in the Health Service which
as I understand it is absolutely uh
stood by
um our spending cuts the right thing to
do you should always review government
spending I mean I ran a huge business
for many years you can't just go much
bigger than that exactly you can't go on
year after year without reviewing your
core that is good business it's good
leadership of the public finances would
I advocate big cuts in the Health
Services of course not the country is
crying out for investment in the Health
Service and that's why boris's
government did it and I believe this
government will support it but that
doesn't mean Sophie we shouldn't have an
intelligent conversation about value for
money in public spending and that's
what's been proposed what would you like
to have seen a full obr forecaster at
the same time in the budget is it's not
slated until the 23rd of November I'd
like to see it come forward very as soon
as possible frankly because there's an
issue of confidence here I mean what
what actually has happened last week is
the huge majority of things that were
done in the final in the financial
statement the market had already
expected them and actually was accepting
of them and the biggest issue of course
was 150 billion pounds for energy in the
market got that but then there were
probably some surprises and so what
we've got to do is actually reassure the
market and one of the best ways of doing
that is with the predictions from the
obr what what surprises do you mean well
it's clear the two the I mean the
chancellor used the word didn't he
rabbits out of the Hat I mean you
couldn't get more evidence that that's
where he was thinking and I think the
two things that were probably the
surprise was the top rate of tax and
that's what's generated all the
observation but my key point is the huge
financial investments were not the
surprises and the market had accepted
them before it happened do you support
the
if it was me I wouldn't have done that
to be really clear I wouldn't have done
that but I understand that the
government is attempting to I agree with
the whole principle of we've got to get
growth going we and it's why I voted for
this trust and I stand by that because
we were in a position that really over
the last seven years we'd seen the
underlying rate of growth of this
country's economy softening you cannot
pay for all the Public Services everyone
expects with that situation so a
different way of thinking was required
and the huge majority of investments in
the financial statement was about that
different way of thinking and why
wouldn't you done the 45p uh rate of tax
I know is that what you're saying about
growth and The Wider plan but why
specifically that because because I
think that's the lesson of History if
you look at what's happened uh certainly
in Thatcher's time and what Reagan did
you have to carry the huge majority of
people with you in the early stages of
this and as we're now seeing that's
proving a difficult thing to do but
principle of what the prime minister is
doing is saying we're going to have a
different approach to growth is what I
fully stand by
um you say that you need to bring people
with you and the importance of that and
certainly if you look at the polls and
look at what Jake Barry says you know
we're a long way out you know a poll as
a poll but there is a clear Trend here
and it is quite jaw-dropping leads the
labor the kind of police they haven't
seen since the late 1990s
so so I'm sure they're celebrating that
but I'm sure the mood here will be one
of utter Defiance we've seen incredibly
difficult positions for this party
before remember May of 2019 Theresa May
European elections I think we got nine
percent of the vote so we are not unused
to having to come back from really
difficult positions but the way you do
it is you lay out your stall and you
demonstrate you are going to deliver and
that's why coming back to your second
question I would always say the thing
this party's got to do is show that it's
delivering for people in this region and
my job is to make sure they leave
Birmingham even more committed to doing
that and a lot of MPS though a lot of
conservative MPS are going to be looking
at those polls and they're going to be
very very worried and the conclusion
that they will draw is that the
conservatives are going to lose the next
election and they'd be right when they
far too soon to draw any conclusion like
that we've seen polls move around
they've moved so quickly just in a few
days so so we've seen that fragility in
polls so all that we can do is to double
down on the task ahead of us and
actually demonstrate that the plan is
going to deliver and so that we can pay
for those Public Services get the better
jobs for people in this region okay just
a final thought Jake Barry committing to
climate change at targets but there is
some speculation about the government's
position on it particularly with the
story at the King Charles was advised
not to attend the next cop Summit you've
obviously been someone who has
championed green issues yes for
environmental reasons also the growth
reasons what would your message be to
coming on this I do not turn do not
compromise and actually there is no
conflict between the cost of living
crisis and the climate crisis there
actually can be addressed in the same
way so it's a critical thing that this
party actually has developed really good
position on and we must not compromise
and by the way go and see our electric
bus outside this outside the conference
center and you will see the investment
into Net Zero in this region okay I'll
go and check it out thank you very much
Andy Street there mayor of the uh West
Midlands thank you very much
well the concept is relationship with
business has been up and down shall we
say in recent years traditionally
enforced the party for business but then
there's been brexit the Northern Ireland
protocol Boris Johnson's supposed F
business comment and now of course the
current market at turmoil well the UK's
biggest business organization the CBI
has criticized the government for not
setting out how it would pay for its tax
cuts or they've been more supportive of
some of the growth measures but we're
joined now by the CBI director General
Tony danker thank you so much for being
with you it's good to see you in person
I think it's the first time I've
actually interviewed you it's indeed in
person what are you hoping to see from
conference well look I think the test
that everyone's been talking about for
the last week is whether or not the
government is basically being fiscally
responsible I think there's another test
at Conservative Party Conference the
government set out in this growth plan
nobody's really paid any attention to it
but a set of reforms to drive growth
that are normally not the kind of
reforms you hear from the conservative
party immigration form to make sure we
have the skills we need planning reform
very often conservative councils not
supportive of planning reform Net Zero
is back in fashion onshore wind is back
in fashion now that's what businesses
around the country were quite heartened
by but we are nervous as to whether or
not the conservatives really mean what
they say so I'm hoping this week to hear
a little bit more from the chancellor
the Prime Minister and in The Fringe
meetings that really the conservative
party do put two and a half percent
growth of primary importance to those
other conservative predilections
policies preferences that's interesting
actually isn't it because look this is
government that's all about going for
growth and yet the two things that
you've been talking about there
immigration and planning reform as well
I mean they are in particular things
that is quite difficult for
conservatives to push through do you
think there might be a bit of opposition
to that yes I think there might be and
look those are probably the two things
that come up most with businesses around
the country in terms of what do we need
to drive growth everybody is short of
Labor and skills and everybody is trying
to get projects moving in a country
that's hard to get them moving now full
credit to the chancellor and the Prime
Minister for putting that in their plan
uh and I think we'll all be wanting to
see that they really mean what they say
what what's what is your thoughts on
that you know because the Home Secretary
Suella government has talked about
driving immigration controlling
immigration levels keeping them down are
you have you had any sense from the
Prime Minister herself that she is
prepared to look at immigration well not
yet other than the chancellor raised it
and said they're going to be proposals
coming forward look everybody knows and
we saw this at last Conservative Party
Conference last year that we aren't
going to have uncontrolled immigration
and there isn't a business in the
country that's looking for uncontrolled
immigration but the idea that you can
overnight close down the borders and not
allow in critical skills that we clearly
aren't going to grow in Britain soon
that's just putting growth second not
first and surely now after the events of
the last week the lesson is growth comes
first not second you
believe grocer conferenced many other
people would say right now that
inflation should come first they're
looking at their household bills and
they're deeply deeply concerned they're
looking at what's happened to mortgages
and they are frankly terrified about
what will happen if they are up for a
renewal anytime soon
and surely the biggest tax cutting
program for half a century is
n't stake inflation
well I think it it raises two risks
doesn't it the first is inflationary and
the second is and I think this is what
the markets were reacting to that it
undermines your ability to bring down
debt in the long run and I think that's
right so you have to look at whether or
not these tax cuts are going to drive
growth now we don't comment a lot on
personal income tax it's not really our
business I'm not convinced those cuts
are going to drive growth so just to be
Crystal Clear yeah you're talking about
the decision to scrap the additional
rate of tax for everyone earning over
150 000 you don't think that will really
move the Garland if you ask me for 30
measures that are going to drive up
growth I wouldn't put it in the top 30.
now the chancellor may feel differently
he might want to set out why he thinks
it's going to stimulate growth at the
same time clearly reversing employers
National Insurance clearly not putting
up corporation tax by six points those
things will be helpful to growth and
competitiveness so look I think there's
a lot of reasons why the markets uh find
the budget not credible I think you're
alluding to some of them that are right
but I think the a chance to the Prime
Minister now need to come forward and
explain explain
what they've done why they've done it
why they think it'll work and at the
very least not row back from some of the
commitments that they have made to
supply side reform
um how about spending cuts
um are you concerned about the idea
about a cutting spending yes but look I
think when you borrow 600 billion pounds
if you take the 450 of the pandemic the
150 of the energy crisis you're trying
to bring down debt in the medium term
you're clearly going to have a plan
that's going to have a mix of spending
cuts perhaps some tax Rises I would have
thought as well as some growth now the
exact balance of that we are awake to
hear what the government's view is but
I'd be surprised if you could keep
growing public spending as fast as you
can but you need to be careful because
we all know that after the pandemic
there are critical public services that
need to be restored that's why the
medium term plan is going to be tough
work tough work
um it's there a fairness argument out
here as well I know you obviously speak
on health of businesses that businesses
employ people don't know as well is
there a fairness argument when you look
at what has been not said or rather not
said about operating benefits and that
their personal tax level Cuts yeah there
is absolutely a fairness argument I I
have spoken to businesses all week and
the first thing on their mind was the
fairness argument I don't accept that
you have to trade off growth with
fairness I think you should have growth
and you should have Fair distribution of
wealth and I think that's the economy we
should be trying to build so yes I'm
absolutely as are most of the businesses
I speak to worried about the cost of
living crisis almost above everything
that's interesting what would you like
to see happen on that well look I think
let's wait for the chancellor to come
forward I'm not going to try and pray
out what needs to come we've got
ourselves into a difficult position by
the way we were always going to I think
one of the things the public has to
accept is that if we're going to have
450 billion pounds covered bail line the
government have done a 150 billion pound
energy payout there weren't going to be
any easy choices so I cut the government
some slack for that but I think they
need to restore fiscal credibility
exactly as you say that's to do with
inflation and debt and they need to
follow through this week and some things
that aren't very popular in conservative
circles those are the reforms that will
genuinely get the economy growing do
they also need to bring forward uh
forecasts from the office the budget
responsibility they're not due till the
end of November yes I think that's right
look as soon as they can do them the
better but let's be honest we need to
get them right and getting the right
involves the government's suggesting the
plans they want to do the obr giving
them fiscal implications of those plans
it's an iterative process so I don't
want to rush it so that it's done badly
it needs to be done well but the sooner
we see it I think the more we'll all
know where we're headed Liz Trump's
saying this morning that she won't be
publishing them any earlier I think
that's the right decision look I think
if it takes that long to get a good plan
take that long what you'll need to do
instead in the interim period is
demonstrate on a daily weekly basis that
you are absolutely committed to growth
that you're concerned about inflation
and debt and whatever the government can
do to give the market that reassurance
given that the markets are lending us
the money I think they'll find a way to
do that okay thank you very much indeed
really good to talk this morning Tony
dank about of the CBI
well the chancellor at quasi quantang
did try to calm the nerves with
increasingly concerned concept of MPS
this week when he told them we're all
one team he asked them for patience and
support to implement his economic plans
but there is some concern among many MPS
as repeater polls show labor with very
significant leads that we've been there
talking about this morning we're joined
now by the conservative MPE for South
Derbyshire and former Junior Minister
Heather wheeler thank you so much for
being with us early uh here to
Birmingham to come and talk to us this
morning how would you describe the mood
among concert of MPS this conference
well it's interesting I must be on
different WhatsApp groups to everybody
else because I haven't had a single Tory
MP tell me the things I'll Doom and
Gloom I think I remember after the
fiscal statement was it five newspapers
that said this is the best statement the
conservative government has ever made
and I know a week's a long time in
politics but should we just calm down a
bit should we just see the growth plan
should we just make sure this is going
to happen and get behind the leader that
was undeniably elected in the summer I
mean you say to calm down but I do you
must acknowledge though that you know
many of your colleagues will be looking
at those extraordinary whole leads for
labor they'll be looking at the
extraordinary intervention that happened
by the bank of England to effectively
stop a run on Pension funds you can see
why they're a bit nervous right I can
except of course
um what is the real poll the real poll
are elections and what happened on
Thursday Two massive wins for the
conservatives up in Jake Berry's
constituency
um so people actually voted conservative
with all this noise going on people
voted conservative that's what I hold on
to the important thing here is we've got
a growth plan it's going to take time
we're going to have more meat on the
bones on the 23rd of November my
daughter's birthday so I remember it
very very well really looking forward to
it and it's going to be a great day and
that's what we need to do we've got to
be subtle we've got to be tenacious
we've got to lay out what that growth
plan is about it's our duty to get our
economy to be going again it's our duty
to make sure that inflation is sorted
out it's our duty to make sure that
pensioners and other people have
absolutely got a future that they know
that they want to pass on to their
grandchildren how that's our job How
concerned are you I talk of spending
cuts because look we can all see the
economic picture here we can all see
that we're spending more on debt
interest repayments than the education
but it but it's been very clear from
this government that tax risers are not
the way they want to go how
do you think spending cuts are
acceptable Jake Barris is talking about
trimming the fat or do you think that
many of your constituents might be very
worried about the idea to cut to their
Public Services well you had Andy Street
on just before me
um and Andy and I are really old friends
um I thought his answer to you on this
question was really sensible any
business looks at what they've got any
business looks at
um not spending money on things that
they don't need to spend money on any
new prime minister will have new
priorities any new Chancellor will have
new priorities and it's absolutely right
that they look at the budget that
doesn't mean cuts it means where are we
going to spend more on that's the way we
should be looking at this according to
Liz trust this morning she didn't
consult with cabinet on scrapping the
45p a rate of additional tax on all of
those earning above 150 000 pounds she
said it was quasi quantum's decision
um how much concern is there among your
colleagues about that specific policy
um I think what that actually tells you
is that she believes in deep mental
government she deletes believes in a
cabinet where the secretaries estate of
their department they know the budget
they're going to get let's run it
properly let's run it like conservatives
let's have new priorities that's what we
need to do and that's exactly what you
know we are fed up aren't we with the um
seti that what did it used to be called
the the couch politics where everybody
just sits around and makes it it's not
work like that if you're a secretary of
state you run a big department you've
got a perm secretary you've got two
Deputy firm secretaries now I mean
goodness me there's inflation for you
but didn't that that didn't used to
happen so why's that happened really
weird so take your orders from the PM
and and keep quiet no the Secretary of
State runs their Department with the
with the priorities that are
conservative priorities that's
incredibly important
okay um well let's uh talk a little bit
about um what is happening on back
Ventures uh Jake Berry said that any
conservative MP who votes against the
budget so if you want to vote against
the 45 abolishing the 45p rate attacks
that should be a confidence issue you
should lose the whip do you agree I've
been a whip twice
you know more than only then perhaps
more than anything and um yeah it's a
vote of confidence if it's a financial
motion for the government it's a it's a
vote of confidence and that's all there
is to it but we shouldn't get bent out
of shape over this
um there's a really interesting
interview with Laffer Laffer Curve so I
mean I don't want to do an economics
program on you here but this is where
you have every single government that
has ever reduced the top rate attacks in
the first two years have increased the
tax take that's what all this is about
it's increasing the tax take so that we
do have tax money to pay for the Public
Services you can't have public services
unless you have tax you can see though
your colleagues looking at those polls
feeling frankly that they don't agree
with the direction that the prime
minister is taking the country in
without an election and now they've been
told that they'll be effectively have
the whip suspended or be removed from
the whip if they make their unhappiness
no
um that's what the whips are for you go
and talk to your web that's exactly what
the whips are for but I urge my
colleagues actually what happened last
Thursday we had elections we won
elections overwhelmingly the Laffer
Curve proves that if you reduce the tax
top rate you earn more income tax for
your government that means we can do
much more with public services and
that's what I want to do and that looks
after everybody that's the whole point
reducing the tax term to 19 beef for
everybody is incredibly important but if
you reduce the 45 you get a bigger tax
take for the government and it means we
can support Public Services where we
need to okay thank you very much indeed
Heather Willie they're good to have you
on the program well that was uh Heather
wheeler or backer of Liz transfer very
supportive of course the way the
government is going and of course we can
talk to an MP now who may have a
slightly different take usually when the
government makes major changes to tax
and spending instead of budgets and this
was a mega budget let's be honest the
independent office for Budget
responsibility would release official
forecasts that didn't happen when the
chancellor announced his recent package
of tax cuts adding of course to Market
concern about the impact on the national
debt
well we can talk now to the treasury
committee its chair concept of MP and
former treasury Minister Mel straise
joins us now
um you've been critical of the decision
not to publish the obr report alongside
the government Liz trouser said this
morning there are no plans to bring that
publication forward from when they are
currently at slated 23rd of November is
that good enough
uh no I don't think it is because uh
right at the heart of the problems we're
discussing here is a lack of confidence
that the markets have had in the fiscal
credibility of the government's policies
and the way that you establish that
fiscal credibility is you have firstly
credible fiscal targets and we don't yet
know what those are or when they're
going to buy it secondly you have the
obr score all the measures including the
spending measures that you've probably
been talking about earlier in the
program and thirdly you have to have the
obr saying that all of that adds up to
hitting those particular targets now the
question then becomes when is the best
time to come forward with that obr
forecast now it's certainly the case you
can't prematurely Bring It Forward and
tomorrow morning would be too early for
example because it is an iterative
process and it takes time but I know
from my discussions with the obr that
they will be ready by the end of this
month to bring a full forecast forward
as opposed to the current date which is
the 23rd of November and why that's
important Sophie is for two reasons
firstly that the earlier you get that
out there assuming that all the numbers
Stack Up and the markets are comfortable
with it the sooner you can start to calm
those markets and the second reason is
that the monetary policy committee will
meet on the 3rd of November are you well
before the 23rd of November in order to
take its decision on how high to raise
interest rates if it has a satisfactory
obr report before that meeting on the
3rd of November I would imagine and
expect that the interest rate rise will
probably not be as high as it otherwise
would be and the reason for that is that
that obr report the fiscal targets would
have reassured the markets there will be
less concern about the inflationary
impacts of the government's policy and
therefore the MPC will be putting
interest rates up by potentially and I
do stress potentially a little bit less
and I say that because these decisions
are very finely balanced the last NPC
meeting for example the vote was split
three ways as to where the movement and
interest rates should go so for
stability reasons and keeping it rates
as low as we can and taking the pressure
off people with mortgages Etc we need to
have that obr forecast before the end of
this month
so just to be crystal clear the decision
to not bring forward the publication of
the obr that in your view is going to
directly hit people's mortgage mortgages
I use the word potentially because to
the extent that the lack of that
forecast means that there's greater
uncertainty in the markets which that
forecast could have calmed down and to
the extent that that in turn leads
members of the monetary policy committee
to conclude that they need to raise
rates a little bit higher than they
would otherwise had to have done then
yes there will be a direct knock on cost
and that's why it is amongst other
reasons so important that that obr
forecast and the fiscal rules the
government's going to work to are
brought forward by the end of this month
yeah
now you've also written to the
chancellor asking him to give evidence
to the sac committee that your chair of
the treasury select committee as soon as
possible in the wake of the budget have
you got a reply yet
uh no my latest letter
um in fact well if in fact we we got in
touch with uh the Chancellor's office a
few weeks ago uh we were told that he
wouldn't be in a position to appear
before the committee until after uh the
uh medium term fiscal plan is presented
on the 23rd of November I wrote to him
uh earlier this week to say that I I
needed to hear from him to see him
before then and I've requested a reply
from him no later than the close of
business on Monday so I have not yet uh
received to my knowledge at least unless
it's sitting in somebody's inbox
somewhere I haven't yet received a
response to that but I would hope to and
expect to by the end of Monday
okay uh now I'm interested to know your
thoughts about the way forward obviously
one of the main reasons the markets were
quite jittery were because of levels of
borrowing Jack Berry on the program
today saying there will be a review of
spending talking about trimming the fat
from government's expenditure how
comfortable are you with the idea of
cutting money from public services
I think it's going to be very tough
indeed because one of the consequences
of higher than expected inflation
compared to what was expected at the
time that those budgets was said is that
of course departments have already had a
real terms budget cut and if you look at
the big budgets like Health like Social
Security like
education and so on
um they are going to be a welfare in
particular they're going to be very
difficult really to lean too hard into I
think in order to make those cuts and
we've been so there's been much debate
for example about whether there should
be an inflationary operating of benefits
well uh they were last uprighted yep
what just to jump in what is your view
on the operating of benefits do you
think they should be upgraded in line
with inflation
uh I I think we need to have a debate
about all these kind of measures in the
round at the time that we have all the
detail and of course we don't yet uh
have all the detail but I do think there
are some very difficult political Optics
um at the very least around having the
45p rate abolished and then uh seeking
reductions for example in the welfare
bill now if you were to uprate uh
welfare payments by earnings rather than
inflation you would save about five or
six billion pounds you've got to put
that in the context of an additional 72
billion pounds that's taking place as a
consequence of 45 billion pounds worth
of unfunded tax cuts that gives you a
sense of how far you've got to push in a
politically difficult Direction in order
to try and square the books here through
leaning into expenditure
I think it also gives us a sense of your
own views on it potentially as well Liz
trouser said this morning that she
didn't consult the cabinet on the
scrapping of the 45p rate of tax that
was a decision for the chancellor
quantity she said do you think she
should have sought a bit more advice
I think she thought she has also said I
think that she feels that perhaps the
the ground should have been laid better
for the fiscal event last Friday and I
think I would put that in that category
in other words it appears to me that
this has been done at you certainly you
know a lot of stuff done at huge pays
quite a radical approach to institutions
and individuals and processes and the
Norms uh and amongst those various
things yes I think something like a move
like that you want to take your cabinet
with you you would want to discuss it
with them and I think that's typically
how that would have happened in the past
um Jake Bearer is also very clear that
as far as he he's concerned if any
conservative MP votes against the budget
or the measures announced in the budget
that will be seen as a confidence Vape
so effectively they would have the whip
removed do you think that's the right
decision
that's uh always typically been the case
that if you vote against a major fiscal
measure in a finance bill then that is
considered a vote of confidence against
the government and the consequence of
that would be to have the whip removed
so I think if that is the position that
is adopted then I don't think it'd be
reasonable to say that that's that's out
of sync with uh with what has happened
in the past I think the question really
will be around the Practical politics of
that because clearly if there are a
number of back benches or a Groundswell
of resistance to a particular measure
um then that would be problematic it is
a question of whether you can hold the
dam or not if you like uh on that and of
course sometimes these these pushes on
particular points can be resolved before
you even reach that point because the
government will on occasion amend the
proposals that it's putting forward none
of that of course on the 45p will come
in for some time because that will be in
a finance bill probably in the early
part of next year
at the same time though it's been pretty
clear from what uh Liz Charleston quasi
quantity have said since the budget that
they have no intention of reversing the
45p measure given that how many of your
colleagues do you think might end up
voting against it
oh well I'm not going to get into
speculating around potential future
rebellions sometime uh next year as as I
said earlier I think the important thing
I'm sure that most of my colleagues will
be doing this will be we want to know
the full extent of this package we want
to know where these spending uh cuts
that the government's now talking about
are going to fall and what they will
mean and indeed you know how they will
impact lower income families who who are
as always at times of of economic toil
generally the group that that suffer the
most so
um I think I and all my colleagues will
want to take a level-headed calm and
reasonable look at the entire package
that's on offer here
it doesn't sound like you are entirely
sure how you will be voting on some of
these measures I take the point that you
want to look at it in the round
but is that still
an open question
well I I don't tremendously repeat
myself Sophie but this this is a a very
big fiscal intervention it has many
moving Parts with huge consequences for
the economy and indeed for individuals
and families and businesses up and down
the country there's a lot happening and
I think it's only right so particularly
when we get this obr forecast as I say
the earlier the better that we really
have a chance to look at that and look
at the detail and see how it all fits
together what the distributional impacts
are for example of all the measures that
are being undertaken and and quite
rightly the government is saying that
you know the the intervention on
supporting uh households or the with
their fuel bills will be
disproportionately beneficial to those
lower income households because they
have a higher proportion of their
expenditure uh that that's accounted for
by energy costs so there are swings and
roundabouts here and you have to look at
it in the round
uh briefly because I I'm out of time but
I want to squeeze one more in
um will this translate the conservative
party into the next election
sorry I slightly missed that when
so say will Liz translate this I will
we'll trust yeah will she I I I
certainly hope so because
um for that to happen I think it's fair
to say that we have to fairly quickly
move to a place where the polls are
beginning to turn around where the
markets are feeling that the government
is behaving fiscally responsible and
they're gaining in confidence and the
pressure on the pound is being uh
released somewhat and bond yields are
not soaring off uh as as we see and if
that doesn't happen so in fact then I
Then I then I think we are in hugely
difficult uh Waters
okay interesting uh stuff now stride
thank you very much indeed we are at a
time
now Vladimir Putin has again made failed
threats to use nuclear weapons uh
following his illegal annexation of some
50 of Ukraine this week feels a very
important uh story for us to cover uh
today uh here we're in Birmingham for
concept of conference but of course at
the war in Ukraine continues with Sham
referendums in four regions which
Ukrainian forces are still fighting to
liberate so we can talk now to our next
guest she's been on the program before
we are delighted to have her with us
again the Ukrainian MP last year batty
lenko who will be speaking at conference
this week
um thank you so much for being with us
we know of course you're going to be
speaking to the conservatives at
conference Boris Johnson was always a
key Ally of President zielinski are you
seeing the same from Liz Truss
we are we are uh seeing the same from
this trust also from her government we
were extremely happy that the Minister
of Defense didn't change so we have a
continuity there of uh of support for
the Ukrainian military for of
collaboration with the Ukrainian
minister of defense
and uh of course all this means that the
UK and Ukraine continue to to work uh on
their strong strategic partnership
I want to talk a little bit about the
situation on the grounds in Ukraine we
all know of course about the
extraordinary bravery of the ukrainians
in a war that many people expected would
be over in a matter of weeks you're
continuing to retake territory what is
the situation on the ground and how
optimistic or not are you
I'm fairly optimistic and despite Putin
trying to distract from from the
advances of the Ukrainian Army in the
east of Ukraine uh the Ukrainian Army is
still advancing regardless of the
annexation announcements regardless of
the Sham referendum all of that is
absolutely meaningless when it comes to
the Ukrainian military units coming
forward and liberating the Ukrainian
people and reinstalling the Ukrainian
flag in uh well pretty much all all
across the the east of Ukraine so we
have the luhan's region the netsk region
we have advancements being made in the
parisia and here's some today and over
the coming days as well so it's looking
pretty good on the front lines for
Ukraine but of course we are still
reliant on the support that we are
getting from our allies including the UK
in terms of weapons and in terms of
ammunition we need those to be coming in
larger numbers and in faster time for
Ukraine to secure a quick Victory
because a quick Victory is is exactly
what the whole world needs today we
cannot be fighting this war for another
year or years to come this will deplete
Ukraine this will deplete the sources of
the allies and this will strengthen the
Tyranny and the Empire that Putin is
trying to build so desperately
at the same time of course Putin has
held these Sham referendo in four
regions of Ukraine where surprise
surprise people voted to join Russia how
is Ukraine responding to that
the thing is people didn't vote
so uh that's the whole point of the Sham
referenda where you have the results
fixed and where you have a bare minimum
of respondents so some two maybe three
percent of uh the population of all
these regions were participating in the
referenda and a lot of the answers were
obtained by actually holding people at
gunpoint or by inflicting threats on on
people and their families uh and even at
that some some were still responding in
the negative that they didn't want to
join Russia and again I I go back to to
the survey results to sorry two percent
of the population of those regions voted
that that's hardly the will of the
people you know this is how Ukraine
looks on these referenda they're just
nothing they're they're just you know a
fiction of Putin's imagination who would
like to see his Empire and stated but uh
we as you know normal sane people who
want to live in the Free World you are
fighting for democracy and freedom we we
cannot take seriously the fantasies of a
psychopathic Tyrant leader
do we need to take them seriously though
because he is also hinted at the use of
nuclear weapons he said that the regions
are now part of Russia so he's Justified
to protect them by all available means
and he also says there's a precedent
created by the United States to use
nuclear weapons how worried are you
about that
well Sophie and all honesty he has been
threatening nuclear uh threats from from
February onwards none of them
materialized the fact that he now has a
legal ground in his mind to treat these
territories as if they were Russia
changes nothing because on the onset on
the 24th of February the Russians
invaded Ukraine saying that they are
liberating Ukraine from something
essentially implying that they were
already treating these territories as if
they were Russia and Putin was clear
that he would be prepared to go to to to
all means in March he mobilized or he
said that he was mobilizing the nuclear
Arsenal to be ready for deployment at
any point it still wasn't used I used I
think that um Russia and the Russian
line of command realized first the uh
the consequences of the use of such
weapons first and foremost for the
people in Russia because it's a nuclear
weapon it's not going to to be contained
within the secretary tree the aftermath
is going to spread the results are going
to to spread to to the territory of
Russia and second the consequences of
using those weapons will trigger a
response from other nuclear powers and I
don't think that's in the interest
interest of of Russia or of Putin no
matter how how crazy and how power math
he is
um you know as I said it's a real
pleasure to have you on the program and
we can only imagine frankly you know
what the last sort of nine months or so
has been like for people in Ukraine so I
just wondered if you might feel
comfortable sharing a bit of that with
us
um you're obviously a politician you're
out there you're making the arguments or
more helpful Ukraine you're also someone
who's been pictured with an AK-47 saying
that you'd be prepared to fight for your
country and you're also a mother
um I think I'm right in saying that your
youngest was still a baby when the war
broke out
how has it been for you and for your
family
a roller coaster that's that's to sum it
up in one word and I think it's been
like that for All Families in Ukraine
one day we we smile and we can't help
smiling because of the advances of the
Ukrainian military at the front lines
the next day we have some news coming in
from the Kremlin which is very much
offsetting and we realize that it's
probably part of some kind of
psychological attack on the on the next
day I will be in tears several times a
day because of the of the news coming in
of the convoys of the civilian convoys
that have been shot at and seeing the
pictures of mothers like me with
children who were trying to get to
safety who were just shot point blank in
their faces or in their backs that's uh
you know
those are things that your brain just
can't comp how do you say the word
psychological
compartmentalize basically put into
boxes and tuned into into compartments
it just gets to you the war gets to you
and I have to live in Awareness that I
am living this war and my family is
living this war with me no matter how
far I am able to actually put them uh
out from the country and into safety but
um you know every single Ukrainian will
be affected and disaffected already and
it's the pain and the tragedy and the
aftermath of the war which we will still
have to deal with even after the Russian
soldiers leave Ukrainian land
thank you so much for coming on and
sharing a bit of your story I'm sure
that you know myself and all of our
viewers would be hoping for you know a
better future for yourself and your
family and also of course all families
in Ukraine as well thank you thank you
well that is it for this week's safety
Ridge on Sunday we're live here of
course at the conservative party at
conference at conference in a moment
after the break we're going to be
running through today's interviews to
see what we learned alongside our Deputy
political editor Sam coats plus at the
podcast available Sophie Richardson
Sunday podcast that should be available
from around at lunchtime in the meantime
thanks for joining us here in Birmingham
this Sunday morning
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hello welcome back to Birmingham where
we are at the Conservative Party
Conference you're watching at safety
Ridge the take where we digest at what
we've heard in the last hour of at safe
Ridge on Sunday but also of course it is
a mega weekend for the conservative
party Liz trust really a defining moment
of her Premiership already after that
Mega budget so to discuss all of that
we're joined live by our Deputy
political editor Sam coats well I was
interested in the interview that we had
with Jake Barry the chair of the
conservative party is there going to be
any sniff of acknowledgment of the
market reaction to the mega budget as I
think I'm going to call it or The
Descent among so many Concept of MPS and
to be honest he came out with a very
strong defense if you like of of the way
forward absolutely no sign so that was
going to be in your own back
that's right Sophie so here we are Liz
truss has been prime minister for 26
days of which 11 have been during a
period of national mourning and just to
remind viewers that during that period
her government has spent 160 billion
pounds we've had Sterling dropped the
lowest level since 1985 we've had the UK
economy put on downgrade watch by the
markets the bank of England has done an
emergency intervention uh mortgages
cheap mortgage will be withdrawed from
the market and the conservatives have
had the lowest polling results really
since yougov was founded and so I was
fascinated in the tone from Jake Berry
conservative party chairman actually so
long a Critic he knows how to Duff up
Prime Ministers actually Jake Barry came
on here what really struck me about his
tone in that interview with you was just
how fighty he was yeah well he was
robust I think it was one word that you
could use a robot Society whichever one
you go for but he came out here it was
if he was pumped up wasn't it you know
he he was ready to to vociferously
defend you know the meeting that he'd
had uh the the drinks reception
post-conference with the chancellor and
with uh was he described it the people
who were the engines of the economies
others would describe it at hedge fund
managers financiers he was robust in
going against the polling that we showed
him showing a record leads for labor
party he leaves Nazi in since the 1990s
well hang on what look at the a couple
of by-elections we've had in Roslindale
was his response to that that's real
voting and as you were saying as well
the markets you know according to him
were overreacting so sometimes Sophie I
I think that politics is kind of fought
out entirely in studios like this one
there's a national debate there's one
side there's another you fight it out
and the public decide who the winner is
This Time It's Different though and the
reason it's different right now is
because whatever we say whatever Jake
Barry says on this program there are
some facts on the ground that are
changing that are very ominous now I
know a lot of people particularly on the
Sunday morning slightly switch off when
they hear the word markets and Market
reaction and it is
complex but it's important and what's
going on at the moment is the markets
are slowly taking flight of this
government the scale of its spending the
way it treats supposedly independent
institutions and that's having an impact
on everybody's life it's making
mortgages more expensive it's making
borrowing for business uh harder and so
it's all very well for Jake Berry to
come out and mount his defense but it
sounded to me when he talked to you
earlier like he was kind of saying the
Market's got it wrong let's have a
listen shall we
markets both react to government
statements and in my experience having
tracked this over a very long period
often overreact so let's see where the
markets are interested no no they can
overact I don't know if they did in this
case I'm not an economist but let's see
where the markets are in six months time
I think that's a far better measure of
the success of the mini budget fiscal
event
overreact according to uh Jake Barron
the Market's aren't a person they aren't
sentient beings they don't have emotions
they do what they do on the basis of a
risk calculation they are judging the
trust government risky and some of her
allies know it talking about some of her
allies I was another person I was quite
interested to hear their voice was Andy
Street he supported Liz truss in a
leadership contest he was very careful
to talk about the things that he
believed the government was doing right
on growth saying that was the right
thing to do but there were clearly a few
things that he disagreed with and he
wasn't afraid of saying that no and here
we had one of the first big figures in
the conservative party who can't be
dismissed as a CNAC Ally because Andy
Street voted for Liz truss coming out
and saying that the 45p tax rate
abolition so uh basically getting the
tax cut for people opening over a
hundred thousand hundred and fifty
thousand pounds getting rid of that 45p
rate which by the way I mean some people
are 70 000 pounds a year better off if
they're earning in the millions quite
extraordinary giving what's happened
happening lower down on the income style
he came out on your show and said that
was wrong
so what we've got to do is actually
reassure the market and one of the best
ways of doing that is with the
predictions from the obr what what
surprises do you mean well it's clear
the two the I mean the chancellor used
the word didn't he rabbits out of the
Hat I mean you couldn't get more
evidence that that's where he was
thinking and I think the two things that
were probably the surprise was the top
rate of tax and that's what's generated
all the observation but my key point is
the huge financial investments were not
the surprises and the market had
accepted them before it happened do you
support the uh the top reps if it was me
I wouldn't have done that to be really
clear
um you know what I do quite enjoy in
interviewing Mayors just as an aside I
do quite enjoy interviewing mares um
because they have their own power they
have their own power base they've got
their own mandate and they are a little
bit more free even someone like Andy
Street who clearly wants to be broadly
helpful uh to Liz trust it's always
quite nice to shout the word Boris
Johnson at you and Look Away
um absolutely because a lot of Tory MPS
the the sort of the the upside of
British policies but also the downside
there's a lot of Tory MPS but not this
conference actually sort of reigning
what they think in public because they
want a job they would have been a
patronage those jobs come with higher
salaries so they don't necessarily get
out there and punch their own government
uh for what it's doing because you know
there's just a chance that they could be
Secretary of State for paper clips
that's not true of our Mayors let's talk
a bit about out concept of quantity
rebellions at shower the other thing I
thought was very interesting from Jake
Barry was that he was clear that in his
mind if you vote against anything in the
budget in the finance bill which we're
not expecting of course till next year
that's a confidence issue you should
lose the whip yes he did slightly road
back from that by saying well of course
it would be the chief whip who makes the
final decision on that but it's clear
what direction and travel they're going
and they want to basically uh stop
anybody who votes against that current
being a consent being presumably
standing in the next election we want to
have a fight on this big thing it's bold
talk often you talk quite bold at this
stage
but you touch there on one of the
bizarre political calculations that
they've made the trust government
announced almost two weeks ago just over
two weeks ago that they were gonna scrap
taxes lower taxes for the richest
they're gonna actually make life a
little bit harder for those uh uh the
lower end of the Spectrum by forcing
them to work more but this is all going
to be put into legislation it's all
going to be voted on not until March so
we've got about six months for
conservatives to think hard about
whether they think this is a wise
political uh path to go down whether
they think that the markets are reacting
uh sensibly
um and decided whether or not they're
going to support it uh all the way
through and that doesn't will know a lot
more by March I mean things are very
very fluid on the day today basis but I
I have to say Sophie um you're just
getting signs from all sorts of Tory MPS
that they might not I mean I thought I
thought you got a pretty big neon sign
above strong I have to say uh even
though he was trying to couch it look
you know what we'll have to look at it
in the round he absolutely was not
ruling out voting against uh some of
those budget measures which as you say
that's a big neon sign and this is
someone who used to be in the treasury
he's chair of the treasury select
committee
um and he clearly has some pretty big
Consultants he's not the only one no
another name this morning is Michael
gave one of the most famous cabinet here
along with Liz Strauss one of the
longest serving Canada Ministers of
course until Liz truss's government came
along at which point Michael gave was
out and sacked but can't see back where
she's seen that because Liz truss has a
sort of Fairly famously uh difficult uh
relationship with him so you've got a
sense there that there are people
gearing up for a fight there are many
many more below the surface I have to
say uh who talk privately to me about
what to do they are very very worried
about the direction of travel because of
the impact of the market on mortgages
now the biggest thing that this
government has done uh as Jake Berry
made clear as his trust has been out and
about making clear this morning he spent
a huge amount of money 160 billion
pounds trying to get energy prices lower
now that's going to save people probably
somewhere in the region about a thousand
pounds a year off their energy bills
because of spiking prices we all know
that but why I'm not sure everybody's
come to grips with and this is the scary
bits the bit that's scaring Tory MPS is
that mortgage rates are going up now of
course a lot of people on fixed rate
deals but two million people 1.8 million
people over the next year will have to
renegotiate their fixed rate deal when
they signed it interest rates are
incredibly low maybe one two percent now
you've already got base rates at near
you know two and a half or so you are
remortgaging at four percent or five
percent in English this is hundreds of
pounds a month on millions of people's
mortgages
now you thought the cost of being
pressures were high already on the basis
of inflation and on the basis of
mortgage of energy prices you ain't seen
nothing yet if Market instability feeds
through to higher mortgage costs many
people can't afford their houses let's
have a quick listen uh shall we to the
CBI darts General this is Toby danker uh
one of these people who again the CBI
you know was relatively uh welcoming or
some of the measures in the budget he
thinks that growth is a good thing to be
pursuing but I was struck this morning
by the criticisms he had um let's have a
quick listen to what he said
so look I think there's a lot of reasons
why the markets uh find the budget not
credible I think you're alluding to some
of them that are right but I think the
chance in the Prime Minister now need to
come forward and explain explain
what they've done why they've done it
why they think it'll work and at the
very least not row back from some of the
commitments that they have made to
supply side reform
you do get a sense of a bit of concern
don't you gosh yes now we're in the
middle of the exhibition Hall in um
Birmingham you can see the Thatcher
theater behind us but in front of me are
all sorts of stands for all sorts of
different companies and I can see all
around there are the big Banks there's
Lloyds over there there's Barclays over
there and I think there are a lot of
people from corporate Britain here
looking for reassurance kind of in the
way that um uh that Tony danker was just
talking about they want to know that
this is not a government that attacks
the independent institutions that
underpinners like uh the bank of England
uh even after the firing of Tom scholar
they want to know that Whitehall will
still play a big role issuing warnings
and they'll be listened to they don't
like the way that the obr the office of
budget responsibility the kind of
financial uh Watchdog has been sidelined
all these things are part of why markets
trust the United Kingdom and the
denigration of some of those into
institutions are part of the reason and
with along with all that big spending
why they've lost a little bit of faith
and people's mortgages are going up and
do you finish I want to talk a little
bit
about Jake Barry and the defense he
mounted for storing the Sunday Times
today now just to remind people this is
a story innocently times uh saying that
in the hours after the budget on Friday
uh the chancellor quasicotte was in a
room of people including hedge fund
managers including Jake Barry uh
drinking champagne although Jake Berry
said that actually at quasiopostale was
to be a soft drink I think let's see
have a listen now to what Jake Berry
said is there an Optics problem
we often have Greek receptions for
donors in the conservative party and in
fact these people should be lauded
because we don't have Public Funding of
political parties and these are people
who go up make money and donate to
political parties in the same way as
they do for the labor party and the
liberal Democrats in terms of that get
together it wasn't a get-together of
hedge fund managers it was actually
Britain's sort of leading entrepreneurs
yes I was there but it's the sort of
normal drum beat of treasurer's events
as we call them in the conservative
party that we have all the time
what'd you make of this son
well look the essay question for Liz
trust this week is can she so can she
show whose side she's on So Stories like
that just do not help quasi quality hot
footing from a mini budget Mega budget
in which he's cut taxes for the richest
made like a little bit harder uh for
those on the lowest and the income scale
to a party in Chelsea uh with a hedge
fund Tory donor uh 30 other hedge fund
uh as Tory donors financiers business
people
um it just makes it look like the party
the conservative party potentially the
party for the rich the toxic thing that
they've always had now and labor picking
up on that on conference as well uh you
know uh Jake Berry there talking about
you know these guys are the engines of
the economy these wealthy financiers and
business people Rachel Reeves saying
actually no the engines of the economy
the people who works in the schools and
the hospitals and so on labor also
wanted to know what's actually said at
these events now I've been talking today
recently to people who go to these types
of events that crazy is at in the last
few weeks in fact and what shocks them
is just how casual quasi quality is
about expressing quite out their views
um now they're not Market sensitive the
government are absolutely right to say
uh he hasn't breached any confidences
but for instance he expresses incredibly
strong views about the governor of the
bank of England Andrew Bailey and people
who work at the bank of England
underneath him not pretty views it has
to be said and I think that kind of
thing that kind of carelessness in their
view is another reason why some in the
city some of the markets are just that
little bit worried about this government
it's a whole package of things a whole
Suite of things that people are worrying
about right now that's why this
conference is going to be fascinating
fascinating and it could not be a more
important as well Sam always good to
talk thank you very much for studying
your alarm and getting on early with us
this morning at Sam coats at their
adaptive political answer I know Sam was
just saying really the stakes could not
be higher for the Prime Minister and her
Chancellor at this conference here in
Birmingham she's been talking this
morning at no sign of any a change of
course after the market reaction and of
course the whole reaction to that budget
and certainly that was the impression
that we had on the program this morning
there's going to be lots more coverage
of this coverage of this conference here
on Sky News going forward and do make
sure you check out the podcast if you're
interested in the show and some of the
analysis behind the scenes that will be
with myself and after school
correspondent Liz Bates coming up later
today that's it from safety Ridge on
Sunday the take this morning a good to
see you at this Sunday the scene on
Wednesday
[Music]
foreign
[Music]